today I'm announcing that the United
States will be sending 31 Abram tanks to
Ukraine the equivalent of one Ukrainian
Battalion secretary Austin has
recommended this step because it will
enhance the Ukraine's capacity to defend
its territory and achieve its strategic
objectives
the Abrams tanks are the most capable
tanks in the world they're also
extremely complex to operate and
maintain
so we're also giving Ukraine the parts
and equipment necessary to effectively
sustain these tanks on the battlefield
when we begin we'll begin to train the
Ukrainian troops on these issues of
sustainment logistics and maintenance
soon as possible
delivering these tanks to the field is
going to take time
time that we'll see we'll use to make
sure the ukrainians are fully prepared
to integrate the Abram tanks into their
defenses